let's toss cells back a little bit to
when you first met trigonometry the very
first time which for a lot of you would
be last year okay and when you learn
about trigonometry okay hopefully you
learnt that trigon it's about
three-sided figures three angular
figures I'd say some triangles and
whenever you see metric on the end of
something it's about measuring things
right so geometry is about measuring you
know the sizes of shapes areas there all
that kind of thing so this is something
about triangles right when you first
meet them what kinds of triangles are
trigonometric ratios about remember
right now we're trying to variance to
draw with me a right angle triangle now
this is all familiar right then you pick
an angle you designate an angle we tend
to use Greek letters for angles so
that's a theta over there if we say okay
this is the angle within this triangle
that I'm interested in we then introduce
all these need words we say okay there's
a recall sign which we abbreviate so
just as I am to make it shorter right we
have this other one called cosign which
you just abbreviate you cause and then
we have this own contingent which we
appreciate it really eight to ten right
so you learn about these three things
and you say when you apply them to
disabled okay it tells you a
relationship between some of the science
right help me out
sine theta what would it be equal to
like what's that actual Rachel what's
what's the ratio defined as its opposite
cosine cosine think back to yourself
okay Jason and then of course your last
one ten you can think of two ways the
first way you learn is you go opposite
over adjacent right and so that's why
where you get sohcahtoa out of this
right but there's a second way which you
may not have seen before
but if you have it's okay that's what
we're gonna be focusing today see how
you've got these three things these
three Cordys think clearly they are all
related to each other right
you got your up Society your JC psyche
hypotenuse tan right if I had some
numbers on these likes a typical riding
boot track would be 3 4 5 you get again
3/5 4/5 3/4 ok these numbers the
exercises you get given you just say ok
work out what sine theta is okay what
guys theater is and on another line and
you're just working out numbers but what
doesn't get emphasized so much community
would come in grabs it what does it get
emphasized so much is that these three
things they must be in totally late they
have a relationship with each other so
you can see for instance right this is
one of the less obvious things but it's
him right and it's not just the
relationship between these two sides
okay just came in to get your things out
you can see if I take sign and divide it
by cosine right you see this see they
both have the same denominator right so
if I did society divided by cosine okay
I could just quickly write this up this
is going to be officer on my part news /
increases and because they have the same
denominator which I just pointed out
those denominators will cancel right
there you go they disappeared
you just get left with opposite on
adjacent that's 10 right
okay so not only is 10 a relationship
between two sides just a minute but it's
also relationship between the other
ratios right now that's just one example
there's a deeper one oh that's the one
I'm gonna fix it up for half this lesson
which is that did you ever notice sine
and cosine right they almost have the
same name does anyone don't tell me
don't shout out but does anyone know why
they almost have the same name anyway